[Music]
so in 1997 James Cameron makes Titanic
and it becomes the highest-grossing film
of all time that wins 11 Academy Awards
including Best Picture you would think
that this guy could then do whatever he
wanted what happens he disappears
[Music]
so it's been over a decade and now
finally we have a baton he's basically
spent the past five years focused on the
film but why did it take so long and
part of the answer stretches all the way
back to when Cameron saw Star Wars a lot
of people came out of that film thinking
God that was awesome but for Cameron it
was more call to arms he's like that's
the film I should have made it pissed
him off and it's not until now the first
time since he began as a filmmaker that
he is actually making his intergalactic
space act his own stuff
[Music]
he wants it to be better than Star Wars
he wanted to be better than any space
film ever made so he's done things like
he's invented his own language he's
hired a linguist for USC and so that
takes time it takes time to develop all
your own flora and fauna all these all
those aliens that live on the planet all
the plants that inhabit the planet the
gravitational pull of the planet he's
calculated all these things for the
first time I think something like 60% of
the film is 100% CG so for the first
time he has a total control over every
element on screen you know if there's a
leaf over there that's pointed left and
he wants it pointed right he just says
flip it one of the things that he
developed was what he called the virtual
camera and what it is basically a
monitor that he can hold up on a
soundstage and he sees Pandora the world
that he's created I think the bigger
technology is the 3d camera that he
developed he developed a camera with guy
named Vincent pace that shoots very high
quality very good 3d images and he
developed it specifically for avatar his
next film is likely going to be battle
angel which is based in a Japanese comic
and it's going to use similar
technologies it's going to be heavily CG
he'll use everything that he developed
in Avatar technology wise in battle
angel
you